I have normal blood pressure, but my heart rate is higher than normal. Sometimes I'm sitting
and it is a hundred or more. Why could this be happening? Well, if you have normal blood pressure,
but your heart rate is higher than normal, there could be several possibilities.
If you look at your latest blood work and you look at your vitamin D levels, I'd be interested
to see that because what are the things that you think of? The first thing that you think of with
elevated heart rate with normal blood pressure is a vitamin D deficiency and it's a very common
people with a VAQG defect. So having a deficiency in vitamin D which I would say anything lower than
60 to maybe 80 would be too low of vitamin D and could cause heart rate increase.
There's other reasons for heart rate increase too. You could have some calcification,
some of your neurological communication to your heart. So you have
stimulates in your brain and in your chronic arteries that stimulate and balance heart rate.
Also, heart rate is controlled by the sympathetic nervous system. So different
amounts of stress can increase heart rate. So if you have an elevated heart rate while you're
just sitting there and calm as a cucumber and there's just no way I have any stress in my life right
now. I'm just calm as a cucumber and my heart is elevated. It can be due to some different
nutritional things too. So I think first vitamin D can be some there can be some even things like
food sensitivities or something like that that can stimulate
sympathetic response. If you go to our blog again and you search sympathetic or parasympathetic
you'll see a video, a blog post and a video describing the difference with sympathetic and
parasympathetic and you'll see exercises that you can look at that can help calm your
sympathetic and another sheet of exercise in these are PDFs that you can download ways to
calm your parasympathetics or to stimulate your parasympathetics. So that's the things that you'd
want to look at. What I used to do a lot of functional neurology would have similar questions to
this where people didn't have cancer but they had heart rate variability issues.
Call me their sympathetic was the key then hyperactive sympathetic so there's neurological
exam where you could actually test for this but you'd have to be in person and I'd have to test
you neurologically. But that is a common issue is that an increase sympathetic tone. So you might
feel call as calm as a cucumber but your sympathetic nervous system isn't hyperdrive.
Give me an example about this here's another Instagram video that I just saw the other day that said
nobody should be wearing sunglasses sunglasses are bad for you they're not that that sunglasses
actually cause skin cancer that's what the person did and there was a clip from a podcast where a
person was saying sunglasses cause skin cancer and the reason was in part of what he said was true
sunlight on your retina stimulate your body to release this certain enzyme that is beneficial for
your skin. Well that is true but excess sunlight on your retina how much of that do you need
to to help with with releasing that enzyme excess sunlight especially with somebody who has had
a lot of stress in their life which you could probably list every person as an adult in that category
excess sunlight will stimulate your sympathetic nervous system that has has purposes to stimulate
your sympathetic. However we already have an increased sympathetic nervous system that some people
are prone to because of certain neurological issues in excess hypertonic sympathetic nervous system
and excess hypertonic sympathetic nervous system is going to cause a deficiency or a lower
parasympathetic they go in a balance like a teeter totter so if you have a hyper sympathetic you're
going to have hypoparasympathetics and when you have hypoparasympathetics you're going to have a
decrease immune function increase risk of cancer you're going to have a decrease detoxification ability
because it's all controlled by your parasympathetics you're going to have the hyper stimulation of
the sympathetic is going to cause an increase heart rate can cause high blood pressure but that could
be spared and an increased rate of all cause morbidity because it's going to you're not supposed to be
in a hyper sympathetic state. Your sympathetic nervous system is for fight and flight immediate
response to to help you through an immediate crisis it's not meant to live there so when we live
in a hyper sympathetic state we end up with sympathetic overdrive disorders and heart rate is going to
be one of those casualties so look at that and I will say that wearing sunglasses going back to
that example help calm your sympathetic direct sunlight to your retinas though it does stimulate that
enzyme that can be good for your skin also stimulates your sympathetic so while I don't think you
should wear sunglasses 99% of the time even if you wore sunglasses that were that blocked 50%
of the sunlight and you're out of the sun you're still getting enough to stimulate those
enzyme production while you're still calming your brain to not put you in the sympathetic
overdrive or to help prevent that so again and other I watch Instagram videos just like you do
and I give it because it's like this is just wrong information at least we need a balanced comment here
so and so that means I had to be careful watch it watch lungs answer it for how do I decrease
how do I know what's causing my heart rate increase could be neurological and the neurological
component is going to be sympathetic could be food driven could be you know just stress driven which
is going to be sympathetic also so look at that video and download those sheets and start doing some
of the exercise that will call be your sympathetic your sympathetic are housed in the part of the
brain called the messing cephalon so that sheet I think says messing cephalon messing cephalon call
be nexercises and then your parasympathetic are housed in the vagal nerve so the other one I think
says vagal nerve stimulating maybe it's as parasympathetic stimulating exercise so download both of them
they're different little different exercises some seem silly but they actually do work hopefully that